uh well congratulations I suspect that
you liked it in our studio that's why
you won the game and that you came back
tell us a little bit about this position
uh you played a four did you analyze
this move before
actually no I did not analyze but I
liked it with idea A5 and somewhere
maybe taken this takes C5 and then
before or something like that so
before Castle I played A4 because I
wanted to she will take him on G3 to
open this H file
it was actually a waiting move at the
beginning yes okay that's good some
ideas so after Queen is seven we
absolutely loved A5 then maybe in the C4
then Bishop C2 Queen A5 and Bishop H4
yeah
so did you know already that you're
going to play G4 and Bishop F6 here I
had some ideas and after Queen d8 I
liked G4 more
yeah I was thinking G6
and probably H5 and I think I have some
counter play
um like the computer I don't know why
but G5 he thinks he's oh maybe 35 and
then H5 yeah
G5 yes and then H5 yeah probably four
engine it's not bad for black but for
humans it's not easy to play I think
and
so let's have a look at this
continuation
um tell us a little bit about your
thought process here of course the
computer has no feelings evenly it's the
this position is completely winning but
when you're attacking you're looking for
the best continuation here yes
especially during time travel it's not
easy to find the best continuation so
um I had some ideas yeah
yeah that's a very nice moves yeah
to calculate with everything and it's
not easy you know
okay so let's get back because we don't
have too much time so the position where
I think that uh maybe did you see this
yes if I they yes this idea before night
view three I was thinking also E5
so D4 and as you see you know the
position is very complicated so I think
both of you played well I don't know
probably we made some mistakes during
time travel but
I wanted to show you closer towards the
end that actually after H5 G5
E6 is the terrible blunder because I
think the computer uh thinks that he
well black is winning
and but we understood that your idea was
just the uh to play did you want to play
maybe first
um sorry
um
Queen takes E5 I could not find
more text King take
h8 English well you're not winning but I
think there was some kind of a draw
which I found I don't know miraculously
it goes like this then rookie seven you
protect you protect and you use your
geometry and then the computer says that
this is a draw
nice but after E6 it's
better for black yeah yes I think so
let's get and here even I didn't see
your ideas yes she missed Queen the
frequent before
so that was already game over here and
the rest is the matter of the technique
you played almost the same end game you
know
so what did you think well well you were
playing trying to convert your advantage
here
so uh did you know how to win
yes so the technique was perfect well
congratulations once again I was
wondering if Yasser has a question
because he always has a question in
store no on the contrary we're not
worthy we thought your attack was great
we loved the intuitive play A5 Bishop F6
and it it really was a great attacking
game or congratulations keep it up and
thank you for teaching us how to play
Rook and games yeah thank you for the
lesson on The Rook endings and we are
looking forward to seeing you tomorrow
thank you Bella thank you
wow